welcome to this video playing and fork
the night walk may be okay the Queens
gambit I don't really aah quickly five
now a queen's gambit is not one of the
strongest points of my repertoire I
mostly play not very not very critical
stuff against it but what he's doing is
also quite curious playing with them 40
97 hmm do you go to sea for here or not
sure yeah it's a bit uncommon what he
did here allowing this and 93 or b3
Bishop be 20 possible yeah I bishop this
bishop on c1 it's not really great iam
trying to use the light squares this is
why I'm exchanging this Bishop one b7
like if he changes Queen takes Knight to
c6 maybe an idea I was expecting
suspecting Quincy 7 really but okay
knight c6 years Queenie aid which not
really it's not troubling him very much
I believe okay okay just recaptcha
k 1996 not very dangerous yeah I don't
really have a great plan in this
position Wow I know it gives me a plan
that's nice play against the upon
certainly debatable this was a great
idea okay let's the last game i had this
back rank issues i don't want want that
again let's make sure I don't get back
rang mated okay maybe protects you for
for a moment that is not easily
sacrificing the exchange down this can
be an IDM giving up the exchange 1c4
especially if he gets a pawn maybe the a
pawn for it
ya black ass plaque is probably all
right him it looks the same the e porn
look Sam looks weak but it's not so easy
having queen bee 7i I'm I don't really
know but I thought Queen on d7 I drew
can see six protect c6 but now he's
moving the Queen away he wants to do
something active okay I came then I'll
double why not nexus 7 interesting but
maybe I got Bishop f4 now activating
this Bishop increasing the pressure
I don't know maybe he needs to give up
on c4 give this give this exchange up on
c4 at some point okay so i can take now
one night Knight b6 salt sound might be
six we move the rook takes takes only
six my dad's that's actually quite
strong yeah that looks quite strong he
may be needs to take on b6 now but then
okay to get him and take on his six I
must be good for white somehow
can you take on deform 523 attacking
defined attacking me seven ok so we
removed the bishop mmm this is hanging
ok if we if i play rocky five where is
putting the Queen will be five to see
six maybe but then i have d 5 with the
temple ok that's a that's good on 95
also possibility but that this is a self
pen not if I ok d5 taking the Queen I
should beaut
and now to f5 maybe time warning to h5
has not winning
85 I cannot take 26 is going to win
probably
of a gamble I really hope that removed
you five Queenie six is winning but I
didn't can take with this I can take
Eric with a check just the porn i guess
the time check check check oh no aah
come on this is aa aa no come on this is
not really happening right ah white
resides hey it's really this is this is
really amazing is this a self-made
quality the y 2 news in two moves i find
it I mean like reliably after this total
demonstration yeah great this was so
winning check completely uselessly
winning now come on I can even take the
beef or pawn here it's just even easier
and I have lots of time on the clock
check and simply any check this is
amazing to play rookie folia the only
way to lose this really everything else
basically is is winning yeah can what I
really don't like I don't want to look
at the scam again okay thanks for
watching